what I found really interesting is that
um in like v-tubing I've noticed that
they even though it's you might like a
particular V2 but from a particular
company yeah I've realized that they've
been like the the groups have been
really really smart about getting you
invested more so in the brand name as
opposed to the talent so that when
you're like oh this we don't want this
Talent anymore it's like all right well
people will still want the brand it was
pretty impressive yeah yeah it's like I
think if if idle companies had figured
this out this would be game over the
contracts would be like 100 to zeros
well I mean yeah you pay us well I mean
Japan basically did that with the with
the Johnny's Group which is like oh yeah
the biggest like Idol which is right now
getting a lot of [__] wasn't that the
guy who was like sexually harassing
what's this yeah I I haven't heard about
this uh so uh the the guy who found it
yeah so I don't know the full story I
was gonna make a second shot I think he
made like okay this again like maybe you
could pull up a battery yeah so Johnny
so Johnny's is basically the biggest uh
Idol uh agency in Japan for boys for
boys right uh so like they produce like
smap arashi like pretty much like all
the top [__] boy bands in Japan which
were [__] huge
um and the guy who owned it uh Johnny
something he's like a half Japanese guy
um he I think he died recently and all
these allegations came out about how he
was just like horribly sexually abusive
by the way these allegations had been
known publicly for like 20 plus years
but you know in Japan uh a lot of the
agencies have a [__] ton of power over
the media because uh you oh you have a
Saturday TV show that has variety if you
talk [__] about any of our agency you
[__] goodbye Talent well I mean if
you turn on if you turn on Japanese TV
at any time during the day there was at
least one Johnny's Idol member like
hosting or co-hosting or being on one of
these shows like they are everywhere on
Japanese TV and so yeah yeah like this
[__] story camera but like you know
as you were saying with uh with YouTuber
agencies I feel johnnys has done that
where it's like even if one group
disappears or they disband or whatever
and a new group comes out and you think
to yourself oh this is just a new group
yeah whatever oh they're part of
Johnny's though yeah yeah okay now I
gotta [__] check it out you know and
it's like they've used the name Johnny's
as like a brand power to be like even if
it's someone completely new completely
irrelevant to what you used to like yeah
just based on their association with
that agency people are just instantly on
that yeah and that kind of power that he
had allowed him to do heinous very
horrible yes for decades yeah right um
you know and he got away with it because
now he's dead yeah even though even
though it was publicly known that he was
doing this before and it was reported
elsewhere you know it was never pushed
in any of the uh the the news here again
because Japanese news is from where I've
seen this you know they don't report
things negatively a lot about the
government ever uh and they they let's
say if there's a talent agency again if
you're going to report negatively you
don't get any challenging shows so that
that story almost reminded me of that
what's that British I was gonna say this
reminds me of Jimmy Savile Jimmy Savile
yeah yeah it is literally like that yeah
I was like yeah British so much better
we would never do that that would never
happen
this has probably happened in many many
many countries yeah yeah you're so
popular that you can get away with doing
this heinous [__] yeah yeah uh or you
can just use your company's influence to
bully other companies around yeah do you
want and it's [__] up but hey I mean
again when we when we call the [__] out
in Japan or whatever it's not that we're
trying to be like look at Japan look at
all the problems yeah it's like no
obviously [__] the UK is a [__]
mess what happens everywhere I just
think it's important to point out and
talk about it when you talk about the
whole industry as a whole yeah exactly
of course I mean everyone knows that
there are some uh dodgy [__] going in
the Auto industry we everyone knows that
now you know it's like the worst kept
secret in yeah I I the idol like [__]
like companies yeah everyone knows that
they're treated like [__] yeah yeah
that's why that's why we're watching our
shinoka right yeah yeah
they sell a dream and that's why they
could yeah that's that's the thing no
matter how much comes out as long as you
sell that dream uh people are going to
buy into it you know that's why that's
why Idol master was a five head move
because you can't abuse an anime
characters
that's that was their way of being like
these pathetic human beings with their
emotions they're too unreliable yeah
yeah we can milk them for money but we
should make AIS or [__] characters
that have their own mind and we'll say
what I want them to say and we'll
promote anything I want them to promote
yeah and then that way I don't have to
worry about it everyone wins if a
person's okay with it yeah I'm gonna
[__] do that that it is just a matter
of time before that happens like the
like the first AI Idol group or the
first AI V tuber group you know we've
we've we've we've gotten to the point
now did you hear about that uh
influencer the maids and AI version of
themselves uh you mean was it amaranth
yeah she just announced it but another
streamer who's doing another only fans
person who was doing yeah yeah yeah
amarantha is coming out with her own
like AI version on the cell phone yeah
yeah which is right imagine just jacking
off to like an AI conversation just like
what the [__] yeah man can you imagine
like a trash cheese one who's like hey
you can have a conversation with the
boys come come come drink with us man
yeah you're just like uh pooping poop
and stinky
bread
it's like are you eating crusts get
those out of here get those out of here
you know it's it's so it's I mean it's
so weird seeing that you can just I
guess sell your own image now but just
have an AI version that they can
interact with so you're not technically
selling yourself but you are kind of at
the same time where how how do you like
morally draw the line or where'd you
morally draw the line with that well
that's the big topic isn't it yeah yeah
yeah I guess with that argument it's
kind of up to the individual really yeah
comfortable doing it then it's like all
right well fine then no one's but maybe
no one will give a [__] yeah there you
go yeah because it's so weird because
like I've like I've been on like YouTube
shorts uh like recently and there have
been some videos it's getting scary to
me now because there have been some
videos where I think the voice is AI
generate like like there's oh no there's
so many of them yeah so many so some of
them are like super super obvious like
I'm I'm hearing like a story of like 50
Cent about how he made like his first
million or something yeah and like this
sounds believable enough that maybe this
could be a out of context clip but this
could also be an AI generated monologue
as well and I'm not sure which one it is
and the only way the only way I check is
I go in the comments and I'm like oh
this is AI generated I was like okay
thank God something felt off about this
and I wasn't sure if but I was just over
judging isn't it terrifying though that
you had to ask other people to confirm
that that's what's so scary to me and
like who knows like all those people in
the comments section might also just be
like getting it wrong yeah yeah exactly
it was a genuine I think this I genuine
so many times has happened now where I'm
like I think this is AI but it wouldn't
surprise me if this was also real
because I have no idea everything that
Joe Rogan has talked about in his
podcast
um and I was just like I and I'm just
like this is actually [__] terrifying
because it's getting to the point now
where I'm having to question whether
some out of context clip is actually AI
generated or is actually a real
monologue that I'm hearing I think I
think uh Philly D said it best where it
was like the AI you hear today is the
worst it's ever going to be yeah and
it's like that's [__] terrifying to
think about that like it's gotten we're
talking about how good it's gotten over
the past like even just year and it's
just gonna [__] because Genoa
terrifies me the most right
um I've had moments where I've heard an
out of context clip from trash taste uh
that has obviously been clipped by a fan
yeah and I've been like I don't remember
[__] saying this
the proof is right there the proof is in
the proof is in the uh video of me
saying it so obviously I said it on like
a previous track yeah but if I don't
remember what I'm saying now with real
content how the [__] am I gonna be like
like is that an AI or is that just a
memory issue that is a memory issue and
that is an AI issue that I'm calling out
now because there might be an AI like
generated voice line of me that I'm like
I don't remember saying that but [__] am
I gaslighting my am I getting gas there
by any minor I might have been dumb
enough yeah
and put it out of the realm of
possibility for me to actually say this
but I think I said it oh my God don't do
that I guess the gaslighting us
gaslighting us in a [__] 2025 AI
generated trash days content
of God said some real racist [__] here's
the context so it's just like I don't
remember no that's not there are some
things I know I wouldn't say but if
there was like a shitty food take I'm
like I don't remember saying that but I
did say maybe I just did say that you
know I couldn't put a past myself to say
that yeah I did say that semen tastes
okay
but yeah no it's uh it's terrifying but
yeah I mean yeah going back to the idol
thing I did uh saw them perform and I
was like I don't get this and then they
ended it off with I think one of the
most
one of the most famous like akb48 songs
I think it was [__] fortune cookie or
something like that oh yeah I don't
[__] know I don't watch this show
yeah yeah and I was like [__] got a bit
of Serotonin right now oh no
this is how it starts I'm I'm you know
you say that you missed the whole Idol
train you're probably better off because
I was in Japan when the idol train was
kicking off and it was unfucking
avoidable like it was God damn
everywhere to the point where my I
tricked myself into liking some songs
that was the only way I could be like I
need this torture to end I'm just gonna
tell myself that this is a banger and
then after a while I was like this is
unironically a banger
is that how they do it could you do that
with any song If you just hear it enough
times you could trick your brain into
thinking you know I used to hate this
but now it's kind of it's kind of fire
now yeah I don't I don't know uh have
you ever been to an Idol concert
yourself uh no uh you wouldn't catch me
dead in one but
but that you know there's been so many
like again like Japan loves to do this
thing where like if there's a if there's
a song that's popping off at the moment
they're like how many stores can we put
it in oh my God yeah yeah in Tokyo even
just in Tokyo yeah so the point where
it's like you could be walking just down
the street in Shinjuku and you could
hear the same song coming out of like
four different stores at the same time
and it's just like and that was like
that with AKB when they first came out
like some of their like biggest hits I
was just like okay well [__] yeah we
can't go outside anymore I I figured out
the reason why uh hearing like fortune
cookie like fired off some serotonin in
my brain uh because I was like
I don't know something about this fuel
was homely and I I don't know I don't
know why and so look it up uh and it's
got like [__] 200 million views yeah
the being the bnk48 has like 200 million
views God damn God [__] damn what the
hell yeah
and I was and uh Sydney told me oh yeah
uh they play that all the time in like
supermarkets in Thailand I was like no
way I would remember this and she was
like no no how have you never every time
we go to like a convenience store in a
7-Eleven in Thailand they play this oh
my God and I was like did I just get
Gaslight into liking an idol song like
is this is this on the soundtrack of
your life
and I'm like this this subliminal
messaging have this much power over me
I'm like and I'm like uh I guess I guess
I'm just another sheep following uh
classic sheep yeah classic sheep it's
it's always it's always the songs that
are just like placed in the most
discreet ways right right where it's
just like you don't even notice you're
just like you listen I've had so many
moments where some person has like shown
me a song where I've heard a song on
like YouTube or something right yeah and
in the back of my head I'm like this is
definitely the first time I'm hearing
this but why do I think I've heard this
before and then I realize it's like oh
it's been I've heard this song maybe
like 50 times just unknowingly yeah yeah
it's just like it's and then everything
clicks together and you're just like oh
[__] that's how they do it that's how
they get them that's how they just
[__] do that you think that's where
Deja Vu comes on uh come come here yeah
probably like it's just like I've
experienced this before maybe in a dream
or something but it feels oddly familiar
and I don't know if I don't know if it's
uh got any scientific backing oh sure
figured it out figured it out yeah I
didn't know Thailand was like that man
yeah I I'm just fine on it I'm finding
out new things as well yeah I know